Let's consider what happens
when we have an object that's
moving on a horizontal surface.
So here's our object,
and here's our surface.
Now, we want to look
at a special case
where we're applying a
force F to the object,
and the object is moving
at a constant speed.
Then what we see
here is that there
has to be some type
of force that's
opposing this object, the
interaction between the object
and the surface, that's
distributed over the surface.
For this, I'll write an arrow
here to express that force.
That's the tangential
component of the force.
The object is also pressing
down on the surface.
The surface is pressing
up on the object.
And so there's another
perpendicular force
to the surface,
which is referred
to as the normal force.
And the total vector sum
of these two forces--
the perpendicular
part, the normal force,
and the tangential
part-- is referred to
as the contact force.
This is what we'll
call kinetic friction.
Now, when the object is
moving at a constant speed,
we know that, from experiment,
that the kinetic friction,
the magnitude, is
proportional to the magnitude
of the normal force.
And the constant
of proportionality
is called the coefficient
of kinetic friction.
Now, this law is telling us
something very interesting,
that key properties
are, one, that it's
independent of the contact area.
Now, what do we mean by that?
So let's look at the
following picture.
Suppose we have two
objects of the same mass.
On the surface, we're applying
a force F and the contact area
here, A1.
And we have a similar
object, the same mass,
on the same surface.
And both objects are
moving at a constant speed.
Now, these objects
have different areas
of contact, A1 and A2.
But the force necessary
to move the object
at the constant
speed is the same.
And because of that, the
kinetic friction is the same.
And that indicates that it's
independent of the contact
area.
And the other key property here,
which we'll write over here,
is that it's independent
of the speed of the object.
So we'll write that as
independent of the velocity.
And these three properties
of kinetic friction
are crucial for understanding
the motion of objects
across a surface.
But we still don't have a
very good theoretical model
for explaining this,
although today, there
is a lot of
contemporary research
which has made a lot of
progress in understanding
this interaction.